das schauen wir einmal auf die
neuansteckungen die infektionszahlen
also aus deutschland da sehen wir weiter
dass die in die höhe schießen wir
schieben immer noch so eine welle vor
uns her weil die zahlen ja über die
feiertage zum jahresstart nicht richtig
gemeldet worden jetzt sind wir sozusagen
wieder in der realen welt sagt das
robert-koch-institut also jetzt haben
wir wieder hinlänglich realistische
zahlen wir sind bei knapp 100.000
neuinfektionen am tag das also absolute
rekord werte aktuell aber hier steckt
trotzdem hoffnung drin denn das ist auch
eine wichtige botschaft heute aus dem
chor ohne radar und diese hoffnung kommt
aus dem ausland vor allen dingen aus
großbritannien denn da sieht die kurve
der infektionszahlen mittlerweile so aus
da gibt es ihm genau wie in deutschland
eine spitze und diese spitze dieser berg
der ist aber jetzt gerade überwunden wir
haben in den vergangenen wochen immer
wieder gesehen dass großbritannien
unserer entwicklung etwas voraus es auch
weil die die präziseren die genaueren
zahlen haben und dort ist man aktuell
tatsächlich
zahlenmäßig offenbar über den berg das
ist der omicron pik und mittlerweile
gehen die zahlen seit einer knappen
woche dort die infektionszahlen wieder
runter bei relativ stabilen
verhältnissen auch dort in
großbritannien auf den intensivstationen
auf den krankenhaus stationen noch
einmal der vergleich großbritannien
deutschland die blaue kurve
großbritannien die gelbe kurve
deutschland deutschland steigt weiter
noch die infektionszahlen in
großbritannien singt sie seit einigen
tagen nach absoluten rekord werden also
hier steckt tatsächlich so viel angst
möglicherweise einigen auch diese
spitzen diese rekordwerte machen könnten
hier steckt hoffnung drin in dieser
kurve wenn wir eben auf die entwicklung
in großbritannien schauen ließ
vielen dank die kurve der hoffnung also
sie kommt aus großbritannien und genau
darüber wenn wir sprechen mit dem
statistiker christian hesse hesse in
england heißt es jetzt oregon stadt
omikron das macht hoffnung warum gehen
die zahlen dort plötzlich zurück
ja das hängt mit den statistischen
gesetzmäßigkeiten von sich rasant
ausbreitenden
vorgang zusammen dass sie sich
irgendwann aus sich selbst heraus
erschöpfen
also in deutschland ist es so dass
ein sehr großer teile bevölkerung für
nikon empfänglich ist weil 25 prozent
der bevölkerung geimpft sind dann
ähnlich hoher anteil hat den impfschutz
teilweise schon wieder verloren weil die
zweite impfung schon vier monate
zurückliegt oder länger
insofern ist ein großer teil empfänglich
und daher dieses rasante ansteigen fast
vertikal bei der infektions kurve aber
rasante anstiege führen dazu dass sich
der teil der bevölkerung der für omicron
empfänglich ist dann auch ebenso schnell
wieder verkleinert und insofern gibt es
dann einen peak und nach dem peek ein
rasches abklingen das ist das was
südafrika als szenario schon ende
dezember erlebt habe und dass
großbritannien aktuell sein vertrag ist
vier tagen erlebt jetzt freuen wir uns
für die südafrikaner und wir freuen uns
auch für die briten aber wir würden uns
zu geben noch ein bisschen mehr freuen
wenn die kurve bei uns auch schon wieder
nach unten zeigen würde wann ist das
denn soweit wann haben wir den berg wie
ist offenbar in großbritannien der fall
ist auch überwunden
also modellrechnungen die auch
einbeziehen die die dynamik in
vergleichbaren ländern war
führen dazu und haben gezeigt dass
vergleichbare länder als vier wochen
weiter sind als wir in die infektions
dynamik und insofern ist es ein
plausibles szenario auch bei uns dass
etwa in einem monat bei uns der peak
erreicht sein könnte und es dann zu
raschen abklingen kommt aber bis dahin
ist es unbedingt nötig diesen sehr
steilen anstieg ab zuschläge nicht denn
sehr steile anstiege bedeuten sehr viele
neuinfektionen wir können damit rechnen
dass wir
in ganz kurzer zeit mehr als 100.000
tägliche neuinfektionen haben werden und
obwohl omikron im durchschnitt milde
verläufe macht als delta nur etwa
nur von fünf müssen tatsächlich
hospitalisiert werden
kann es trotzdem aufgrund der großen
fallzahl auch eine relativ große
fallzahlen von hospitalisierten daneben
gehen er soll sie sagen vier wochen also
noch so lange werden die zahlen noch
steigen aber was ist denn die
entscheidende maßnahme die die zahlen
dann wieder nach unten bringt
das ist einfach
ein eine statistische den amish bei
stark sich ausbreitenden und
ansteigenden vorgänger die wie zb auch
ein flächenbrand der irgendwann so weit
um sich gegriffen hat dass es nichts
weiter gibt was abgebrannt werden könnte
und in übertragenem sinne ist das so
dass im moment der anteil der
empfänglichen person für nikon sehr groß
ist aber rasant abnimmt und in etwa vier
wochen ein großteil der bevölkerung
tatsächlich
mit ihrem immunsystem schon in
verbindung gekommen es mit der omicron
mutante und dann nicht mehr empfänglich
ist und dann omikron nicht mehr weiter
um sich greifen kann so dass es immer
weniger neuinfektionen gibt aber eine
immer größere anzahl von genesen
herzlichen dank für ihre statistische
mathematische einschätzung herr
professor hesse